[Applause]
my name is Kiki Vandeweghe I'm the
executive vice president of local
basketball for the NBA I went to at UCLA
it was a fantastic basketball school and
it was very very lucky that I got
drafted by the NBA right out of college
playing for the Denver Nuggets for the
Portland Trailblazers and the New York
Knicks and was kind of a player poached
for my last year in the league for the
Los Angeles Clippers and after that ran
a couple businesses then I got a call to
come and oversee basketball for the NBA
and in charge of the games and
everything you see on a basketball court
I was at the NBA for about a year Adam
Silver was just taking over as the
Commissioner and he really wanted me to
expand my knowledge my management skills
my leadership skills and so he said see
if there's a management program that
makes sons feel it was actually really
easy once I found out that Stanford had
won at Stanford you are instructed by
Nobel prize-winning professors they
interact with you and in a way that you
could never get anyplace else when you
come to the LD you you come to make
yourself better and you come to
accelerate your growth curve and all
these things are about your path and
focused on that which you get out of it
is the ability to make others better
that's what I'm able to do and in my job
make other players better give them some
insight make the NBA League office a bit
of a better place and bring in some new
ideas that perhaps can make not only
basketball but the way we bring
basketball to our fans around the world
a better experience I have changed rules
a little bit at the NBA I was first
hired as a vice president of a little
bit more limited role actually after
this program I was made the executive
vice president in charge of all the
basketball I really do think that this
program had a lot to do with them eld is
is a game changer for anybody who wants
to engage and wants to work and wants to
understand and what you need to bring to
the table is a curiosity eld exceeded
every expectation that I could
potentially have had I recommended that
anybody who wants to not only make
themselves and their career path better
but accelerate the career path of
anybody they work with would do well to
come here to an Ald program
[Music]